[Applaudissements]
l'épicerie a mis au banc d'essai pour
vous vite quelques tirs 4 fut mois 4
presse agrumes une quinzaine de mortiers
4 friteuse et une souris verte elle
finiront-ils comme ramasse poussière
dans le bas de l'armoire
[Musique]
un petit peu 500 toiles pas merci
[Applaudissements]
ça donne ce we
un outil que redoute la gauche le rsa
est une chose
l'onl un problème jeter 4e précède life
s'intéresse qu'au rap et tout ce que
vous voulez c'est pas les remplit manque
sur le marché
aujourd'hui on a un rapport et un
rempart c'est délicieux
ça sert à quoi les couvertures la loi
vraiment beaucoup de dessins c'est
vraiment comme les autres sud
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe ici
c'est une dépense effectivement
sans sac à main ben moi aussi
ah oui
je mettrai pas ça sur ma liste le choix
de cadeaux ce tt ou un non être bien
certaine la chaîne qui afficheront peut
faire un peu en une heure ça fait du
pain a une âme et scalpé un bon ça c'est
autre chose ont obtenu du doublement
stupide
une guirlande de carottes
c'est à 3,86 à la taille est peut-être
un peu à bout de mon temps sur cet
appareil dont le plus jeune
[Musique]
des soupirs raté
la technologie se retourne contre nous
dénie
d'un gars qui s'est passé on les brûle
et que ça c'est pour faire la crème
brûlée
[Musique]
balshaw les problèmes commencent à
pleuvoir
[Musique]
un accident
qui détruit la viande je ne donnerai pas
mon pire ennemi il risque la plus de
moustiques de monsieur
[Musique]
un autocuiseur est-ce que c'est
dangereux
[Musique]